I started assistant directing to learn
and observe and understand how a set
worked and I got in with Clint we got
along well and he just kept giving me
more and more responsibility at
producing wasn't necessarily something I
had intended to do but it was a hard to
say no to glint so I just kept kept
doing it friend of mine Michelle wisely
called me up and told me about the
stories that it sounded interesting so
she sent it over and what appealed to me
was just the characters and their
relationships and the human element of
it all so we worked on a little bit to
try and numb make it a little more
appealing to Clint and he loved it as
soon as he read it and liked the
character very much wanted to play it
and and i think the the you know i was
confident that the it could attract a
good cast as well there just aren't that
many roles for an 82 year old that come
along that feel you know believable and
appropriate to him i mean we get
submitted Dirty Harry scripts and cowboy
movies and I westerns he's just not none
of that really appeals to him anymore so
this one was a role that he felt he
could play and that had something to it
I am a baseball fan I don't really
follow pro ball that much these days
have been working too much but I grew up
you know playing baseball in Little
League and and and really enjoyed it and
so that's what I was trying to capture
in the movie was just sort of that pure
spirit of baseball that you know we all
have is his kids if even if you don't
play and a team you it seems to be
around you everywhere on the radio and
the TV and so forth so I was just trying
to capture that and sort of contrast it
a little bit with the the villainous
character who's all about the
commercialization and endorsements and
all those sort of unappealing aspects of
modern-day pro ball I guess what it came
down to casting and certain roles i
figured put the emphasis on the actor
and find the right actor and then work
with
them on the on the the baseball and then
other people i figured put the emphasis
on the baseball and then we'll work with
the money on the acting so um you know
Amy had never played ball but she's very
athletic and she worked with a coach and
so she could learn to hit and throw and
she's I think she's pretty convincing
and then you know the bow character he
actually played ball in college so he
had some experience he needed work with
coaches to make him look a little more
convincing and then of course the ricoh
at the end he he actually was offered a
scholarship to play ball for college so
and that's right where he was when we
made this movie so he was quite a good
ball player in my case it was great
experience because Clint doesn't he kind
of goes about directing in a rather
informal way he's not he doesn't like to
UM over-prepare because he likes the
spontaneity of things just unfolding on
the set in front of him for the first
time so as a producer that men I had to
be prepared for a lot for whatever he
might need so in terms of assembling the
crew and the cast and equipment I had to
think like a director and figure out
what he might want or what what it is he
was going to try and accomplish so that
was all great experience so when I
started directing this actually I found
it I found there was even less anxiety
because when you're putting all this
stuff together for another person you
never quite sure whether you've got it
and whether you've got everything that
they want but in Mike I knew what I
wanted I had the vision I knew exactly
what my shots were and everything so it
was just a matter of telling people what
i wanted and showing up